こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
最近…
あのー多分皆さんの想像している以上に
僕は裏でとても
ｳﾞｩｪｪｪ↑
皆さんが想像している以上に
僕は裏で実は凄い最近運が悪いんですよ(´Д｀)
まあ今年は厄年ということもあっていろいろあったんですけど
年末ぐらいはまぁ平和に行きたいな　ということで
運勢を変えるためには
神に,天に祈るしかない
それしかないと僕は思っております
もう何でもいいんですけど
もう祈れるものがあればもう僕は祈っておきたい
ということで今日の企画は
こちらに今神社があるんですけれども、
こちら、えー
高杉神社という神社でございます…だよね？
晋作ぅ
全体的に今年も運が悪いんで、
神社で1000回お参りすると、運勢はよくなるのかという検証をしていこうと思います
結局はそういうね
やっぱ気持ちの問題なんですよ(ﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝ
1000回祈ったことによる効力というより
『1000回祈った俺凄ぇ』
みたいな自分に言い聞かせる自己暗示能力によって
自分の運気を上げていくというポテンシャルの問題
総合的に含めてお参り1000回することによって
どういう効果があるか…
ちょっと検証していきたいと思います
押忍！
あのもちろん冷やかしでやってる訳でなく, 僕ガチでやりますから
神社のお参りの方法を確実にやっていきます
まずその一　【鳥居をくぐる】
なので1000回やるときは僕鳥居を1000回以上往復しなきゃなりません
ﾌﾞﾌｩw
鳥居をくぐるときは直前で軽く一礼します
で鳥居の後の道を行って、
中央歩いちゃダメなんだ!?!
神社の道を歩くときは端っこ
道の端っこを歩かないとダメみたいです
中央は神様が通るらしいので
(いいよ、来いよ)
一礼、課金
あっ違っw
お賽銭、二f
二r二拝、二拍手、一礼
で一礼で戻ると…オッケオッケオッケ
一通りのやり方が分かったんで
このマニュアル通り、完璧な動きをちゃんとやるんですけど
ちょっと金の問題がやべえなw
1000回、お参りしていこうと思います
ではいこう
♪～
(ｽﾘｽﾘｽﾘ)
(電話)はい。
(電話)うん。
(電話)リコール?リコールとは？
(電話)え？なに俺の86が故障したってこと?故障ってか故障してたってこと?
(電話)うわマジ～?
点検に行かなきゃいけなくなったみたいですｗ
不幸だ
♪～
はい、というわけでようやく50回行きました
1回1回のお参りを結構真剣に気持ち込めてやってるんで
50回でも相当疲れました
もうちょい頑張ってみます
♪～
はじめ）1000回ぐらい…
お姉さん)1000回ですかw
お姉さん)頑張ってください
はじめ)ありがとうございます!
♪～
はい、というわけでとりあえず100回お参りしました
あの～1つ言っていいですか?
終わらない
あの動作自体はシンプルなんで適当にやろうと思えばすぐ終わるんですけど、
僕ちゃんと1回ずつ本気でお願いしながらやってるんで時間がかかるんですよ
すいません多分このペースでやってると1日だと終わらないので
ちょ空いてる時間を見つけて、何日かかけてちゃんと1000回お参りしようと思います
とりあえず今日は100回で終わっておきましょう
では
♪～
ﾊﾟﾁﾝ
(ガッツポーズ)
♪～
はい、というわけで、え～300回終わりました
暗いな
あと700回頑張っていこうと思います
バイバイ
400回分です(5円玉が)
行ってきます
♪～
残りの50回行きます
400回終わりました
まだ多分太陽が沈むまでもうちょっと時間があるので
あと100回!
やります!
♪～
という訳で無事500回終わりました
1日100回は全然まだいけるんですけど、
200回となると、頭痛というか
多分脳を動かすから
頭を動かすから片頭痛みたいになってとても苦しかったです
折り返しです、あと500回頑張っていこうと思います
では
お疲れ様です!今から200回やって700回分のお参り行ってこようと思います
500円玉200枚分です(5円玉です)
では
♪～
なんか頭がおかしくなりそうなんですけど、
えっと今日はもう100回やって700回まで行こうと思います
では
♪～
あのとりあえずこの回数やって分かったことは、
頭がめちゃくちゃ痛いです
で、お辞儀がその回数が多いからなんか
脳が揺れて脳震盪みたいになっててすごい吐き気と頭痛がすごいです
あと300回、頑張っていきましょう！
ヤバイ今日寒っ!服装ミスった
700回までいったんで今日中にあと200回やって900回まで行こうと思います
では
♪～
♪～（ズーム）
はい、じゃちょっと雨が酷いんですけど
このまま続けて900回までいっちゃいます
では
♪～
850回まで来たんですけど
近所のお兄さんから差し入れで
暖かい飲み物を貰いました
ありがたいっす、マジで助かります
今日あと50回頑張ります
ﾊﾟﾁﾝ（拳で？）
♪～
ヨッシャー!（ガッツポーズ）
というわけで900回終わりました
あと100回で1000回なのでラスト100回、頑張っていこうと思います
ちょっともうメンタルがボロボロっす
では
♪～
えー1月1日でございます
今900回お参りしたので
この新年、1月1日で
残りの100回無事終わらせて最高の1年を切れれば良いかなと思っております
あと100回…
がんばるZOY!
もうここまでくると寒くないっす
もう僕は900回のお参りを通して
不屈の心を手に入れたので、もう気温は関係ありません
やっていきましょう
♪～
ﾊﾟﾝ　ﾊﾟﾝ
はい、というわけで皆さんあけましておめでとうございます、改めてはじめしゃちょーです
えー1000回お参り、本当に辛かったです
めちゃくちゃ頑張って、めっちゃかっこよさそうに見えるんですけど、
絶対マネしないでください（真顔）
1日200回のペースにしてから、
お参りした後いつも頭痛と吐き気で寝込んでました
お辞儀のし過ぎですごい脳にダメージを与えてしまったんで
皆さん絶対マネしないようにしてください
で実際1000回お参りした後の僕の運なんですけど、
今年1発目に、まあ今年1発目どんなもんかなと思って、
コンビニで1番くじ引いたんですよ
1番くじ引いてみたところ、
ED♪～ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑
ED♪～ﾃｰ↑ﾃﾚﾚﾚ↑ﾚｰ↓ﾃﾚﾚ↓ﾚｰ↑ﾃﾚﾚﾚ↑ﾚｰ↓ﾃﾚﾚ↓ﾚｰ↑ﾚ↑ﾚﾚ↓
ED♪～ﾃ↑ﾚﾚ↓ﾚｰ↓ﾚｰ↓ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑ﾃﾞｭ↓ﾃｭ↑
ED♪～ﾀﾀﾀﾀ